they are in such serious trouble so then
one thing they do know though is that
kamala harris has to go kamala harris
cannot be the person who runs in 2024.
so this brings us to cnn's hit piece and
now i don't think that cnn runs pretty
much anything without someone from the
white house being behind it i just don't
think that's the way cnn operates cnn is
an adjunct wing of the democratic press
press spokesperson essentially so
there's a piece there by edward isaac
davier and jasmine wright it is titled
exasperation and dysfunction inside
kamala harris's frustrating start as
vice president
oh it's gonna be good guys do you see
how the turnabout is fair play here
everybody was thinking man i was not
ready for this this surprise ending you
know everybody thought that when joe
biden picked kamala harris he would need
a food taster because
like he wouldn't want to stand you
wouldn't want joe biden standing at the
top of the stairs of air force one and
kamala harris standing anywhere within
like a three foot radius right because
just one slip and uh and kamala harris
is president well what if it turns out
that joe biden has put out the
pre-emptive political hit on kamala
harris
wouldn't that become glorious and
hilarious
well that may be what's happening and
yeah i'm here for it it's enjoyable worn
out by what they see as entrenched
dysfunction and lack of focus key west
wing aids have largely thrown up their
hands at vice president kamala harris
and her staff deciding there simply
isn't time to deal with them right now
especially at a moment when president
joe biden faces quickly multiplying
legislative and political concerns the
exasperation runs both ways interviews
with nearly three dozen former and
current terrorist aides administration
officials democratic operatives donors
and outside advisors who spoke
extensively to cnn reveal a complex
reality inside the white house many in
the vice president's circle fume she's
not being adequately prepared or
positioned and is instead being
sidelined
the vp herself has told several
confidence she feels constrained in what
she's able to do politically
yeah they keep saying every time you go
out and get in front of a camera you
look like an idiot those around her
remain wary of even hinting at future
political ambitions with biden's team
highly attuned to signs of disloyalty
particularly from the vice president
she's a heartbeat away from the
presidency now she could be just a year
away from launching a presidential
campaign of her own given doubts
throughout the political world that
biden will actually go through with the
re-election bid in 2024 something he's
pledged to do both publicly and
privately yeah here's the other thing
joe biden doesn't want kamala harris
around because he sees her as a threat
and old joe still has the idea that he's
going to run for reelection and by run i
mean hobble toward re-election
few of the insiders who spoke with cnn
think she's being well prepared for
whichever rule it will be by the way you
shouldn't have to well prepare the vp i
thought the entire idea was that the vp
is ready day one in case god forbid the
president goes down
i'm sorry this is not a tutoring class
you don't get like remedial vice
presidenting once you become vice
president of the united states you
should not be selecting somebody for
vice president of the union this is joe
biden's fault honestly you shouldn't be
selecting somebody for vice president
who needs like remedial math
if this is not you went to high school
and then they're just passing you
through and then finally you graduated
like 57th in your class of 75 and uh and
then you get to community college and
jill's there teaching you how to do two
plus two equals four that's not what the
vp slot is supposed to be here
a few of the insiders who spoke with cnn
think she's being well prepared for
whichever role it will be
again i just i love the image with just
kamal hair sitting there and somebody's
standing in front of a blackboard
explaining to her what the vp role is
and how she's going to fulfill it
harris is struggling with a rocky
relationship with some parts of the
white house while longtime supporters
feel abandoned and see no coherent
public sense of what she's done or
been trying to do as vice president
being the first woman and the first
woman of color in national elected
office is historic but has also come
with outside scrutiny and no forgiveness
for even small errors as she will often
point out
[Music]
by the way always a great look it
doesn't look peevish or whiny at all to
sit around as vice president of the
united states talking about how
everybody's mean to you oh it's so sad i
mean she doesn't get any forgiveness for
small errors now small error is like
saying that she's been to the border
when she hasn't been to the border ever
and not understanding why she should go
to the border for example or being
charged with getting coveted under
control and then completely failing at
that
literally everything she's tasked with
she fails at defenders and people who
care for harris are getting frantic says
cnn remember this is cnn this is not fox
news this is coming directly from biden
okay there's only one way that this
piece gets run and that is the white
house is looking out there and they are
saying she needs to go get rid of her
now we need another shot at this
defenders and people who care for harris
are getting frantic when they're annoyed
some pass around a recent onion story
mocking her lack of more substantive
work one with the headline white house
urges kamal harris to sit at computer
all day in case emails come through
when they're depressed they bat down the
aaron sorkin style rumor that biden
might try to replace her by nominating
her to a supreme court vacancy
that chatter has already reached top
levels of the biden orbit according to
one person who's heard it oh yeah good
luck with that
good luck with that nominating kamala
harris to the supreme court of the
united states based on her extensive
experience being terrible at everything
man talk about just failing upward this
would be the greatest example of failing
upward i've ever seen she fails as a.g
in california
by the way pushing the totally
unconstitutional and ridiculous notion
that the ag of a state can simply refuse
to defend a law in a given state and
then courts can simply refuse to
adjudicate the law this is what she did
with proposition 8. she said i'm an ag
of the state i don't like traditional
marriage the voters in my state like
traditional marriage i don't i refuse to
challenge those i refuse to stand up for
that law in court and then the ninth
circuit court of appeals is like well if
the state of california isn't standing
up for its own law i guess we won't even
adjudicate it it's just ridiculous on
his face she's a garbage aj she was a
garbage senator this is when i was in
california so i know and now she's a
garbage vp and now they're like what if
we put her on the supreme court we're
gonna just if she keeps failing will she
eventually become a deity like seriously
we all have to sacrifice to kamala
harris we throw virgins into volcanoes
for kamala harris if she keeps failing
this way we'll just keep moving her up
the food chain until we all genuflect at
the actual altar of kamala harris based
on her sucking at her job royally it's
unbelievable
by the way apparently this is like a
thing in democratic party politics terry
mcauliffe just lost his virginia
governor's race which is nearly
impossible to do
you know hard you have to work as a
democrat to lose a virginia
gubernatorial race you have to work
super hard at it
and i'll say this for terry mccall if
you worked super hard at losing that
dude was dedicated to losing he lost to
glen younkin first thing that happened
the bite administration came around
knocking on his door saying you want to
be in the bible administration like the
failure upward is just a stun joe biden
is a great story of this right joe biden
ran for president 173 times he's been
running for president since william
jennings bryant was challenging him in
primaries and now joe biden is president
of the united states you can just keep
failing upward presumably
according to cnn harris is perceived to
be in such a weak position that top
democrats in and outside of washington
have begun to speculate privately asking
each other why the white house has
allowed her to become so hobbled in the
public consciousness at least as they
see it again i love that her own
failings are now jobiden's fault
joe biden is a doddering old fool and
the biden team's like why can't why
can't he help her and she was like
and then he falls over and clunks his
head
we'll continue on this because it's it's
glorious it really is
talk about dysfunctional okay as i've
said before
when it comes to politics folks
understand politics is never house of
cards it is always veep it is never
house of cards it is always v but it's a
bunch of morons running around like
chickens with their head cut off
directly into walls until they knock
themselves unconscious and then tax you
that is what american politics is and
politics of nearly every sort all right
so cnn's story this hit piece on kamal
harris continues
quote she's very honored and very proud
to be vice president of the united
states her job as the number two is to
be helpful and supportive to the
president and to take on work that he
asks her to take on said alini kunilakis
the lieutenant governor of california a
longtime friend luna lack spoke with the
vp last monday morning before harris
departed for a diplomatic mission to
france it is natural that those of us
who know her know how much more helpful
she can be than she is currently being
asked to be said kunilakis that's where
the frustration is coming from
an incumbent vice president says cnn
should be a shoe-in the next time the
party's presidential nomination is open
but guessing who might launch a
theoretical primary challenge to harris
has become an ongoing insider parlor
game other politicians with their own
presidential ambitions have started
privately acknowledging they're trying
to figure out how to quietly lay the
groundwork to run if and when harris
falters as they think she might
the reality is more complex and looks
different to people more familiar with
how any white house actually works
harris is the first vp in decades to
come into office with less washington
experience than the president finding
her footing was always going to be hard
oh
so sad
presidents and vice presidents and their
staffs often clash barack obama's west
wing tended to be dismissive of biden
staffers and biden himself had a number
of stumbles early in that job
republicans and right-wing media turned
harris into a political target from the
moment she was picked for the ticket and
implicit
racism and
sexism have been constant
that's it's not that she sucks at her
job it's racism and sexism that's that's
the solution and by the way joe biden
picture for racism and sexism why he
picked her openly i need a black woman
for the job he said and thus he picked a
black woman i don't know who's being the
racist and the sexist other than the guy
who literally said he's selecting on the
basis of race and sex
but says cnn it's a conundrum unique to
her people are expecting their historic
vice president to make history every day
when in fact she's trying to carry the
duties of a secondary role harris is
being judged not just by how she's doing
in the traditional duties of a vice
president
said minion moore a longtime democratic
operative who's become harris's most
important outside advisor
it's a little more subliminal but it's
real what's her playbook in history said
more
harris has emerged as a quiet force in
the administration said more oh is that
and she focuses attention on different
issues sometimes just by her very
presence in the room
oh
that's a good way of putting
stand in the corner and say nothing and
where the dunce cap please
she's a quiet force in the
administration that's amazing you know
this kleenex box right here it's a quiet
force on my show it's been sitting right
here on the table this whole time doing
pretty much nothing but you know really
this is this kleenex box right here
i think it's been having a market impact
on the quality of the show doesn't have
to have any kleenex in it by the way i
think it's empty i think we need a new
kleenex box but it's been doing it it's
doing a q it's a quiet force it focuses
attention on different issues just by
its very presence in the room
love it love it that is a hot take right
there from minion more her quiet
presence in the room just standing there
like a thing
i love this too uh it's so good okay the
story just gets better from cnn with
many sources speaking on condition of
anonymity to discuss the situation more
frankly they all tell roughly the same
story harris's staff has repeatedly
failed her and left her exposed stalin
has never failed only stalin's staff has
failed him
to the bianca with you
yes
um
that you harris cannot fail harris can
only be failed
even some who have been asked for advice
lament harris's overly cautious
tendencies and staff problems which have
been a feature of every office she's
held from san francisco d.a to u.s
senate
cnn continues biden aimed to model his
relationship with harris on his own vice
presidency and directed aides early in
his presidency to employ her in similar
fashion he arranged weekly lunches just
as he's held with obama and invited
herod and invited harris to join him for
his morning classified intelligence
briefing harris meanwhile threw herself
into proving her commitment to the
president and the administration using
his relationship with obama as her guide
even then some white house aides
questioned whether biden's experiences
vp would easily translate to someone
with far different qualifications and
skills and to a much different moment
after harris became known in the first
few months were often standing by
biden's side in the frame as he made big
speeches even after she'd introduced him
herself the white house the west wing
appears to have overcorrected
so she's been with the president
noticeably less not just in public a
week and a half ago as biden and his
aides and multiple outside allies
rattled through calls all day trying to
lock down wavering lawmakers ahead of
the house infrastructure vote harris
spent the afternoon touring a nasa space
flight center in suburban maryland we
weren't going to cancel her schedule
just because of the house's foolishness
that harrison explained
um well alternatively the white house
was like yeah we don't need you in the
room making calls to people if you'd
like to go see the spaceships and the
nice telescope and and we can hire some
kids so they look excited that happened
they literally hired children to be in
the room with her that's how popular she
is that's that's exciting stuff they
were like actual that was reported so
good times over there with kamala harris
the next morning biden singled her out
saying a lot of this has to do with the
lady right here the vice president but
that's not how things have played out
no indeed it is not so
apparently joe biden had basically
shuffled her off to nasa to hang out
with the children and then he brought
her back and he's like she she
contributed a lot she she you know she
she really helped me out i am
but says cnn that's not exactly how
things had played out
while she had attended some meetings
biden hosted with key lawmakers there
were many more she didn't attend to the
point it was noteworthy she made an
unscheduled drop by one session in the
final stretch
harris had only been in washington four
years to the white house just one time
before being sworn in as vp
so in other words she didn't know any of
the senators and no one cared about her
and no one liked her so sending her to
the hill was completely pointless
harris's aides cite how much of what's
in the infrastructure bill connects back
to legislation she worked on well in the
senate including accessible broadband
wildfire defense water cleanup and clean
energy school buses ooh school buses
perhaps one harris aid offered the issue
is that some in the west wing don't have
constant knowledge of what the vp team
is doing we feel like a central
component of the effort overall another
said
harris has also complained to confidence
about not being a greater part of the
president's approach to the afghanistan
withdrawal despite telling cnn at the
time she was the last one in the room
when he made the decision leaving her
without more to draw on when she
defended him publicly
wait so she she's so politically
incompetent she wanted to be closer to
the center of the afghanistan withdrawal
that is something like that that line
right there tells you everything you
need to know about kamala harris's
political instincts
joe biden destroyed his presidency on
the shoals of afghanistan he decided to
precipitously withdraw from afghanistan
leave hundreds of american citizens
behind leave tens of thousands of siv
holders behind leave 19 million women's
the predations of the taliban and kamala
harris is like why can't i be in the
room for that why can't i be at the
center of that
man this lady has the political
instincts of a badger trying to cross
the i5
like
very bright bright when harris picked
her when biden picked harris as his
running mate he was essentially
anointing her as the future of the
democratic party says cnn
now many of those close to her feel like
he's shirking his political duties to
promote her essentially setting her up
to fail her fans are panicked by her
fans we mean her and doug amhof again
watching her poll numbers sink even
lower than biden's worrying that even
the base democratic vote is starting to
give up on her
says a top donor to biden and other
democrats kamala harris is a leader but
is not being put in positions to lead
that doesn't make sense we need to be
thinking long term we need to be doing
what's best for the party you should be
putting her in positions to succeed
on the one hair on one issue harris is
actually asked to be assigned voting
rights progress has been slow because
biden is focused on passing his own
domestic agenda even though harris has
said privately the filibuster must be
scaled back if real progress can be
achieved
and though harris has told confidence
she's been enjoying a good working
dynamic directly with biden those who
work for them describe their
relationship in terms of settling into
an exhausted stalemate
suspicion says cnn has sprouted out of
bitterness last month white house aides
leapt to the defense of transportation
secretary pete butterjudge
harris loyalists tell cnn they see in
that yet another example of the unfair
standard to play wondering why she
didn't get similar cover any of the
times she's been attacked by the right
it's hard to miss the specific energy
the white house brings to defend a white
man knowing that kamala harris has spent
almost a year taking a lot of the hits
the west wing didn't want to take
themselves instead of former harris aide
so now come it's going to be so much fun
guys because booty judge is going to run
against her and it's going to be kamala
harris being like you only like booty
judge because he's white and puja is
going to be like you only like kamal
harris because she's straight
it's going to be intersectional joy all
the way down it'd be lots of fun
white house aides said they weren't
pitting one against the other the
difference in the responses those aids
think was that buddha judge hadn't done
anything wrong
who to judges leave was a conveniently
timed reminder that biden is pushing for
a national paid leave law that's
different from when harris has created
problems for herself white house aides
believe such as when she didn't push
back on a student who accused israel of
ethnic genocide west wing aides weren't
going to clean up after that
but even when white house has faced her
own manufactured outrage from the right
like when an innocuous tweet about
enjoying the long memorial day weekend
was said to be insulting dead veterans
white house aides also remained
virtually silent
and then cnn continues along these lines
harris's team is mad biden assigned her
to handle diplomatic relations with the
northern triangle nations in the hopes
of addressing root causes of migration
but gave her no role on the southern
border itself
as cnn has previously reported harris
herself has said she didn't want to be
assigned to manage the border aware that
it was a no-win political situation that
would only sandbag her in the future but
biden's team was annoyed that harris
kept fumbling answers about the border
as somewhere around heresy at the white
house failed to come to her defense
bidenates have repeatedly told herself
they'd love to have her they'd love to
have her doing more and ask the vp's
office to come up with plans for how to
get her involved according to people
familiar with the conversations
though the staffs are on multiple calls
per week west wing aides are often left
wondering why there's not more follow
through
aware of her stumblings and the ticking
political clock harris's chief of staff
tina florina went to ron clayne over the
summer they were drowning and they
needed more help clayne is known as a
kamala harris defender in the west wing
this is the chief of staff and does a
weekly one-on-one meeting with her in
the west wing office to help her
strategize as a former chief of staff to
two vps claim knows the dynamics well
klayne in a statement provided to cnn
downplayed any criticism of the vp
saying harris and her team are quote off
to the fastest and strongest start of
any vp i have seen
[Music]
harris's aides point that biden was
never subjected to the kind of attacks
she regularly or endures or to a toxic
social media culture
and then they say it's because she's too
loyal to biden that's the big problem
she is too loyal to biden
and then she starts blaming her aides
in and around harris's circle they
speculate there must be someone getting
in her way something it's the president
himself leaving her out in the cold some
blame specific west wing aides whom they
feel are out to con whom they feel sure
are out to undercut her
some fear the vice president is leaning
heavily on her sister maya
brother-in-law tony west and niece mina
harris whom they sense exerting
influence over everything from staff
hires to political decisions
several people familiar with the
operations of the vp say that after a
spike in involvement earlier in the year
the family has now been pushed further
out again recently if you expect that to
remain the case
so again she's blaming her operation you
have everybody in the white house
blaming her
you have
her falling apart on the public stage
um she is she's just falling apart she's
falling apart
donna brazile one of seven pr several
prominent black women who urged biden
advisors to put harris on the ticket
agreed that it's time to retweet after a
rough first year brazil wants to see the
vp on the road almost constantly keep
air force too gassed up and ready to go
she joked whether talking about
replacing lead pipes in flint or
expanding broadband in rural america
she's a wonderful messenger but it has
to be clear concise and consistent said
brazil don't make her a creature of the
beltway let her out yeah that's the
issue is that they've been we haven't
seen enough of kamala hair so here's the
funny part the bite administration is
desperately trying to downplay this how
do we know so jen saki
who is back from her covet bout she was
fine she tweeted out
there's a direct quote for anyone who
needs to hear it vp is not only a vital
partner to potus but a bold leader who
has taken on key important challenges
facing the country from voting rights to
addressing root causes of migration to
expanding broadband
[Music]
oh yes there's that energy gotta love
that energy we are so happy we picked up
that blaine gabbert to be our our backup
quarterback now that tom brady is
injured this is gonna go just great we
love her we love her
yeah things are going great over here
blaine gabbert will definite we're not
going to pick up anyone from the waiver
wire lane gabbard is definitely going to
be our long time starting quarterback
yeah
[Music]
jen's hockey really trying to tweet
through it ron clayne doing the same
thing so ron and clean chief of staff
and just retweeted something from a
person named robert garcia our vp kamala
harris just finished a highly successful
trip where she strengthens diplomatic
relationships she takes on the most
complex assignment because she's capable
and smart she's a great leader who also
happens to be funny and kind and that's
the tweet and ronald mclean retweeted
that
so team biden is like okay we're okay
we're going to pretend that we like her
yeah we hate her we're going to pretend
okay sure so
the fact that kamala harris is in a
complete state of implosion and that you
have a giant several thousand word long
story at cnn about the complete
implosion of como harris demonstrates
the democrats are in such serious
trouble they are in the biggest trouble
right now and they know it i mean
they're in serious how serious is the
trouble the democrats are in
according to a brand new abc news
washington post poll
republican congressional candidates in
the generic ballot currently hold their
biggest lead
in 40 years
in four decades is the biggest lead
since before i was born in the
congressional generic ballot
the democratic party's difficulties
according to abc news are deep they
include soaring economic discontent a
president who's following 12 percentage
points under water and job approval and
a broad sense the party is out of touch
with the concerns of most americans 62
say so
and this is the worst number for the
democratic party they're down at 41
in the history of the poll
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content